our lead national correspondent that's
david beckham spoke with a survivor of
the attack a worker at the king
superstore
who says he hid just a few feet from the
gunman david boy that's scary good
morning to you
gail good morning to you this is an
eyewitness who survived the shooting he
hid inside the store
for the entire rampage and he says the
first thing he saw
was when he came off his break he walked
out of the store and he saw the gunman
approaching the store
gun raised and he says the gunman killed
an elderly man
in the parking lot of the store before
he made his way in
i kind of was thinking it was a dream uh
like
none of this was actually happening but
then the adrenaline kicked in
and i realized that this is a life or
death situation year old logan smith
says he and a co-worker spent nearly
half an hour hiding behind garbage cans
inside the coffee shop kiosk where he
worked
as the gunman moved through the store
did he ever say anything
that is the scariest part of it all not
one word
said by the gunmen or anyone within the
building
that i could hear no screaming from the
victims
there was screaming within i would say
the first five to ten
seconds and then dead silence for the
next 30 minutes
the only thing that could be heard was
store music
and the automated store message smith
says shortly before the shooting
he had been on a break with his friend
and 25 year old manager
ricky olds he saw her again right before
the gunman shot and killed her
she was near the east side self checkout
i saw her get shot and i immediately
saw her just fall to the ground uh
instinctively i wanted to rush over
and comfort her but i knew that i would
have lost my life as well if i
engaged in that most of the mass
shootings in colorado have happened
within my lifetime
and the idea of a situation like that
happening
has been ingrained in the back of my
head
since i was a child in every single year
of my
primary education i have done at least
one active shooter situation since first
grade
did that active shooter training you
underwent from
first grade through high school kick in
it did
immediately no one should ever have to
experience what happened that monday
it's the reality of the day we live in
and
it won't be the last time that it will
happen sadly
you know at the end of our interview he
told us that when he comes back to work
here at the grocery store and he expects
to
he expects that kroger which owns the
grocery store is going to provide an
armed security guard
at all times anthony he told us he's a
gun owner and he also said this he said
david i would appreciate the right to
actually bring my weapon which i'm
licensed to carry here to work and have
it on me
because he said after what i lived
through i'd like the ability to protect
myself
and people around me just a surreal
description of what happened in that
supermarket
david thank you